joining us is a man who kicks everything
off right here on nbc sports on peacock
every single day with pro football talk
live the founder of pro football talk
himself mike florio back here on the
program how are you sir rich doing great
pal how are you i am doing fine rash of
injuries at the quarterback position
including mike tomlin just moments ago
um dropping the fact that big ben's got
a peck
yeah inside he said it will affect big
ben's ability to prepare for sunday's
game against the bengals so
another one to keep an eye on you know
we got through all the preseason with
a relatively clean sheet of quarterback
injuries and then week two all hell
breaks loose and big ben
the biggest name that we now have to
keep an eye on
what is the future there i mean what's
the over the steering wheel
um plan and discussion i mean there has
to be i mean kevin colbert's one of the
tops in the business at being your
general manager of the pittsburgh
steelers what do you think is going on
there we know it was a long 20 years for
the steelers between terry bradshaw and
ben roethlisberger they had good teams
but they never had that consistent year
in and year out franchise quarterback
they had guys that looked like maybe
they would be like a neil o'donnell or
cordell stuart but they never really got
there until they went 11th overall in
2004 and got ben roethlisberger so at
some point they're going to have to be
ready to make that move unless
they can end up getting very lucky with
dwayne haskins they liked him in
training camp he has yet to supplant
mason rudolph as number two but he had
been moving in the right direction i
think they were hoping for this year for
him to have a chance to develop quietly
behind the scenes and then maybe he gets
evaluated to the guy who could take over
if ben doesn't come back
next year of course
they don't close the door on ben coming
back next year but it has always felt
like this is it for ben and we don't
know if he's going to miss any time but
they have to be thinking about the
future they have to be because it's far
far closer to the end than the beginning
at this point for ben yeah the first
couple weeks the offense doesn't appear
to be any more crisp or dangerous
um than than the the
offense that fell completely flat after
starting 11-0 and that's despite
drafting
that kid uh naji harris all-world kid
from from alabama and now here comes the
cincinnati team that had a shot at you
know coming back on the bears if not for
joe burrows three
straight pass attempts that went in the
hands of chicago's um
this is no this is no easy one and they
knew that the offense was going to be a
work in progress with matt canada in
charge now juju smith schuster told me
before the season that they were going
to have a lot of different formations
and looks and it was just a ton of
different things ben roethlisberger
himself told reporters it's going to
take some time to get to where they need
to be it is just kind of a weird vibe
offensively you got four new offensive
linemen you've got naji harris there but
you still have ben roethlisberger it's
like a hybrid of the past and the future
jammed together in the hopes that they
can make it work in the present and it
looked great week one it looked good
enough it's not like the offense was
spectacular but when the defense is
playing the way that you did against
buffalo you don't need
the offense to to be one of the best in
the league it's just not going to be
something that that saves them
defensively every week you look at what
the raiders did and they need to be
worried about that happening again if
the offense can't hold its own mike
florio pro football talk a host of pro
football talk on nbc sports
uh net as well as nbc sports on peacock
joining me here on the rich eisen show
carson wentz not one but two
sprained ankles and now they're owen two
taken on a titan's team that uh that
avoided that same fate with a derrick
henry
infused comeback win in seattle so this
is a nasty
set of facts and circumstances for
indianapolis is there the plan is to
just throw the kid eason out there and
hope for the best is that beason was the
clear-cut replacement for wentz when
wence got
injured and had the foot surgery in the
pre-season but then easton quickly lost
ground to sam ellinger ellenger is
recovering from a knee injury so it's
easton who came in and promptly threw an
interception on sunday with the game
still undecided against the rans and
with wence rich i've been trying to
understand exactly what the issue is and
why he gets injured so often and i think
what it comes down to is plain and
simple he holds onto the ball too long
trying to make something happen he got
dragged down by erin donald anybody who
gets dragged down by aaron donald is
going to risk spraining an ankle under
the weight of aaron donald's body you're
not going to see tom brady at sofi
stadium this sunday getting dragged down
by aaron donald he's going to see donald
coming and he's going to get rid of the
ball or he's going to hit the deck
before he finds himself and aaron
donald's clutches that's the difference
and i think that's why carson wentz gets
injured so often he doesn't know when to
call it a day
and save it for the next play and ensure
he's going to be available something
drew brees stressed we did the digital
video
after
halftime of the week one game
involving the rams and the bears and he
made that point and it's such an
important point it's so easy
but people lose sight of it when they
watch the game and they admire when the
quarterback drops his shoulder and
drives through this and holds onto the
ball every one of those moments where
you have contact with a defensive player
in the quarterback is a chance to get
injured you got to minimize those wentz
maximizes those to his credit but
there's a fine line between courage and
stupidity and he's on the wrong side of
it far too often isn't it amazing that
you know leaping for an end zone in the
los angeles coliseum
a couple years ago in an mvp campaign
and getting your knee blown up because
aaron donald hits it didn't sink in
enough for carson wentz to see aaron
donald again i think some guys can't
turn it off i think that's what it comes
down to when you get out there whether
it's your throwing motion whether it's
the way you go through your reads
whatever it is that you're trying to do
once you get out there and it's real
the competitive instinct takes over and
so many people treat that like a badge
of honor it really does become a problem
if it's infringing on your ability to be
available to your team it's not heroic
it is it is idiotic if you allow
yourself to constantly be in a position
where you get yourself injured that's
where wence needs to rain himself in and
i don't know that it can be coached out
of him mike florio here on the rich
eisen show took two weeks for the
reality to just be staring everyone in
the face
um despite all the signs and the the
writing on the wall that there is no
scenario under which the houston texans
would start desean watson this year 0.0
full blutarsky on that front as tarad
taylor god bless him i mean what a
awful set of circumstances always seems
to befall this man when he has
opportunities looks like a hamstring
injury is going to keep him out for the
you know foreseeable future
and i know they got this kid davis mills
that they drafted but
here's a team that
kind of looks really
stout on certain areas when we thought
they would just be completely barren of
talent and competition
do you think there's anybody there
saying why why not deshaun watson why
not desean watson
you know rich one thing that i've
learned and it only took me 20 years to
figure this out when i speak very
candidly about issues with a given team
fans get upset fans of that team get
upset yes in large part because they
don't like someone saying out loud the
thing that they are privately concerned
about but i view myself as kind of an
advocate of whatever fan base i'm happy
happening to comment on their team at
that given time and if i'm a texans fan
i'm wondering what the hell are we doing
we're paying this guy 10.5 million
dollars how does it get to this point
that he's not playing for us why are you
telling him you're under contract you're
playing for us and i understand that
they
don't want
to risk him getting injured and infringe
and impair their ability to get maximum
picks either now or after the season i
get all that and hey there's a chance
the nfl will say hold on no no we would
ought to make a decision about whether
or not to put him on paid leave as long
as you're paying him to not play but if
you're going to play him then we got to
do something that's part of it too but i
think it just comes down to he wants out
they're willing to let him go they don't
want him to play they don't want him to
get injured and he's just off the table
and if i was a texans fan who was paying
good money for tickets to those games or
spending my time that i could otherwise
spend doing other things watching those
games and giving a crap about that team
i would be livid that it got to this
point regardless of who's to blame now
the fact that it got to this point is a
tragedy for the houston texans and it's
made evident by the fact that they're
going from tyrod taylor
to davis mills
or mills davis i think it's
quarterbacks in the nfl at the back up
level where you can change first name
last name i think we've done this bit
before but it's true mills davis
starting thursday night well and it's
possible that driscoll jeff gets in you
know because you know and and that's the
question like so do you think watson
would
would say no like if they went to him
said look look
we we know what's going on here it is
such an
odd situation awkward whatever adjective
you want to use unprecedented that
somebody as generationally talented
as watson is also at the same time
untraitable
and
potentially unplayable like this is this
is a rubik's cube that we've never seen
before mike but like what about going to
him and saying i know you don't play for
us anymore and we kind of don't want to
play her but do you see what we did to
the jaguars in week one do you see
what we kind of are cooking here like
get on board
right
and the way the dominoes fall if they do
something like that it gets ugly very
quickly but they could if they want to
be distracted by it and we talk about
distractions all the time some are real
some are fake this would be real if all
of a sudden they decide they're going to
go to sean and say
we want you to show up and practice and
we want you to really try we don't want
you to half-ass it we want you to show
up and earn the money that we're paying
you and then they're watching him
they're studying him is he working hard
enough is he doing everything that he
needs to do
is he really trying you know it's easy
if he says no then you can
find him suspend him for conduct
detrimental to the team that's easy the
hard part is identifying whether or not
he's just going through the motions and
that's the thing with a quarterback and
this may be why they're doing what
they're doing for all the other
positions you can draw a hard line and
say hey get your butt to work but for a
quarterback you need him to be so much
more than just the guy that takes the
snap and hands off the ball and throws
the passes he's the guy who's the leader
of the team sets the tone shows up early
stays late holds people accountable
brings the locker room together you want
and that's why i'm a firm believer that
quarterbacks need to have more of a
voice in the overall structure of the
team than they get because they're
expected to act like bosses on the on
the shop floor and and if you have a
quarterback who's committed to doing the
bare minimum i don't think that's good
for anybody and that may be why combined
with
we don't want him to get injured and we
don't want to have the nfl say he's on
paid leave and whatever other concern
they have i think that's why they aren't
going to him and saying time for you to
earn your money but if i'm a texans fan
good luck getting my money
if you're willing to give 10 and a half
million of it away to one of the best
quarterbacks in football that you
allowed this to get to the point where
he doesn't want to play for you and you
don't want him to play for you
regardless of how we got here this had
its origins in the dysfunction that was
pervasive in the texans organization
credit to them to get veteran players
who are kind of wiping that stink away
but it was that stink from last year
that has them in the mess they're in now
mike florio here on the rich eisen show
couple more quarterback uh scenarios i
want to talk with you about first one
uh aaron rodgers because you just
mentioned um quarterbacks should get
more say and and clearly that is
what was at play with aaron rodgers from
draft day and before and after until
appearance day
at training camp i had him on the show
yesterday and i asked him specifically
like what what change did you get
that's made you say okay i'll come back
and he basically said it was just trust
and hope that it's nothing you could
stamp on a piece of paper did he get
best on your knowledge
um uh an agreement from the packers that
we'll trade you if if things don't go
the way for either one of us this year
did he get that assurance
i don't know
he did and rich you know there's a
belief out there that he got that
assurance
in this most recent offseason and the
the fuse
that ultimately was lit
was when
they said to him oh no we're not
going to trade you even though we said
we would trade you after 2020.
and that is the real cause of everything
going off the rails in the off season so
i wouldn't believe anything
that the packers told me verbally at
this point because they already told me
if what i've heard and others have heard
is true
that the packers had promised him they
would trade him after 2020 and then
apparently matt lafleur caught one of it
and said oh wait a minute wait a minute
jordan loves not ready we can't do this
and i don't know that that was the
catalyst to renege
but
so i i'd want
i'd want anything and everything in
writing before i trusted and who knows
where this is all gonna go and you know
rich sims and i were talking about this
earlier today
with the packers and this falls into the
category of packers fans get pissed
when someone points this out but if i'm
a packers fan i look at this and i say
this damn corporate structure does me no
favors you had jerry jones
on
the uh game day morning show the other
day yes
and i understand there's a a potential
drawback to having a jerry jones and
daniel snyder a single person who can
be that driving force behind an
obsession to win a super bowl
corporate structure
i don't know where where is the
obsession where is that one person with
that overriding force of personality who
will say hey you know what we got close
this year
but we weren't good enough
here are the areas we need to identify
just like the chiefs what they what they
do their offensive line stunk what'd
they do they spent a ton of money on
their offensive line they took advantage
of opportunities to improve their
defense
in green bay i feel like they're content
to be in the general vicinity of the
porch
and hope that once every 10 to 15 years
they'll stumble
up onto the
the welcome mat and kick in the door
whereas you've got these other teams
with owners like jerry jones who are
obsessed to bang on the door each and
every year and and i think that's the
fundamental cause of aaron rodgers
concern because the reason they're in
the vicinity every year is him look
around him i mean they got some good
players but what do they do every year
other than draft and develop what do
they do they don't go out and identify
guys who could come in to make a
difference right now big name players
key players that just has been not a
part of the culture there and i think
the corporate structure has something to
do with it mike florio bringing it today
here on the rich eisen show last one
interpret for me what happened in
chicago yesterday where brad pitt
where where brad biggs uh who covers the
bears asks
um matt neggy if
if
dalton is healthy is he your starter and
he says he doesn't want to get into
scheme
biggs pushes back saying that's not
scheme and you know nagi with his usual
smile goes of course it's scheme and i
understand he would say that it is
scheme because the game plan with dalton
and fields are completely different you
don't want to telegraph anything to the
browns
but then a pr representative comes back
in the room big tweets out that
the missive the note the message from
bear's pr is dalton is the starter if
he's healthy that's the answer
what is happening like what
what is going on with fields not getting
the start it's definitely dalton if he's
healthy
what what is the push pull here this is
all part of that broader effort by the
bears to delay
the launch of the justin fields career
until they believe he's ready it's about
making sure he's ready not getting him
out there prematurely and
hurting his ability
to be as good as he can be next year i
think the the deal that necessarily was
done when they traded up and gave up
next year's first round pick to get
justin fields is that everyone's getting
judged based on what fields does next
year
so anything that happens this year is
about making sure that you maximize
the performance level of justin fields
next year and i'm not saying they're
treating us like a red shirt year
scholarship year whatever but
it would be
beyond ludicrous for the bears to fire
matt maggie ryan pace and or ted
phillips after this season when you've
made the investment in justin fields so
next year is when everyone's on the
clock with whether or not field is any
good so if they think
that
not putting him in a situation where he
has you know four interceptions in 35
minutes or getting beaten around behind
an offensive line that maybe isn't as
good as it needs to be and they'd rather
defer as much of it the next year as
possible that's where it's coming from
but but rich this andy dalton injury
gives them a chance to just kind of give
him a test drive
and if justin fields fails you don't
have to say he was benched you just say
andy dalton's healthy and when's andy
dalton healthy he's healthy whenever
justin fields is deemed to be not good
enough to get it done it's perfect it's
falling right into their laps if they
choose to play it that way
i just don't understand why the pr
aspect of it isn't you know
um i guess that it it does matter you
know what you're saying and how you're
terming it either the kid is ready to
start or not the kid went to ohio state
pardon me the ohio state and threw the
entire damn route tree on clemson and
from the whole country to make the
national championship game for crying
out loud you know i i i
i'm mystified you know i i am just a
little bit confused as to why the bears
are not just going to go and throw them
in and take the lumps that the jets the
jaguars are clearly taking right now
that the patriots are once again immune
to
um with their quarterback i i kind of
don't get it mike i'll be back
big cat has said from time to time
dysfunctional teams do dysfunctional
things
and that may just be the ultimate
explanation at the end of the day but
they've got this guy that they believed
in they traded up for
and there's that hesitation to go all in
and i really do think it's about being
careful now
because next year is when
they really want to get the absolute
most out of justin fields i asked the
poll question of mike before we send him
on to the rest of uh his tuesday chris
yeah mike out the door which owen ii
team do you still have faith in
colts falcons giants vikings
probably the vikings because they could
easily be two-and-oh you know you got
john gruden feeling good about the
raiders being 2-0 they easily could be
0-2 it just shows you how
how thin the margin is
on so many of these games and with 17 of
them now
to go through one of those close
heart-wrenching games win or lose you
gotta start all over again and do it the
next week it really is an amazing grind
and the challenge for the on2 teams
especially the ones who could have won
either of both games forget about those
games don't let that owen 2 become 0-3
simply because you're feeling down on
the mouth because you're owen too mike
appreciate it we'll see you on pro
football talk uh in the morning and then
of course anybody who wants his new book
that comes out in march called
playmakers uh how the nfl really works
parenthetically and doesn't uh go
pre-order it right now where all books
can be pre-ordered mike thanks for the
time appreciate it rich right back at
you man you got it that's uh mike florio
bringing it
i like it hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here